hi my name is Neil Kenny Guyer and I'm
the CEO of Mercy Corps an international
relief and development organization with
many programs throughout the Middle East
in North Africa with a special focus on
creating jobs for young people and if I
were to say what is the one thing that
could be done to really boost youth
employment and entrepreneurship i would
say focus on social enterprise because
what we're seeing all over the world is
a convergence of organizational models
that blend the best of the nonprofit
world NGO world with the private sector
and that these organizations are coming
together to solve some of the toughest
challenges in our world today and with
the energy among the youth especially in
the Middle East today there's a
tremendous opportunity to promote to
look at social enterprise whether it's
through creating mobile financial
services that serve the needs of poor
people whether or not it is looking at
innovative ways to deliver health care
to provide clean water there is great
opportunity and social enterprise and I
think that that is what so many of the
policymakers and organizations today
should really focus on thank you